[Musik]
jedem ort untersuchung ist wie ein
puzzle das man zusammen setzt
als leitender mord ermittler hat man
eine immense verantwortung
zeugen liefern nur bruchstücke an
informationen
ab dem moment in dem der anruf eingeht
arbeitet man häufig 16 stunden tage
[Musik]
wer es gibt immer fälle die frustrieren
sind man fragt sich was man bloß
übersieht
man muss alle unterschiedlichen
puzzlestücke zusammenzufügen
man steht immer unter druck
manche fälle verschlingen einen
aber man muss alles geben damit die
familien damit abschließen können
[Musik]
[Applaus]
montag 26 april 2010 jason ein
schulfreund von mir rief mich auf dem
handy an er sagte hey meine mutter ist
heute nicht zur arbeit erschienen keiner
hat sie gesehen und damit ihr gesprochen
das ist seltsam
ich hätte in seiner stimme wie gesagt ja
die beiden standen sich sehr nahe und
sprachen täglich miteinander
er wirkte sehr beunruhigt
[Musik]
jason und ich sind seit der siebten
klasse eng befreundet
was jungs waren wir von anfang an
unzertrennlich
wir wohnten nah beieinander ich kannte
seine eltern mut
[Musik]
sie war sehr sympathisch und herzlich es
interessierte sie was wir jungs machten
sie arbeitete in kellys man's shop einem
geschäft für herrn begleitung
sich zum ermittler befördert wurde hat
sich mir geholfen meine anzüge und
krawatten auszusuchen
sie hat mich eingekleidet
das lieutenant körper kaffee kobel und
ihre familie gut kannte war für uns sehr
hilfreich
es erleichtert immer ein wenig die
ermittlungen wenn man den familien
hintergrund kennt
nach dem ersten gespräch mit jason war
ich besorgt und wollte die angelegenheit
sofort untersuchen
er betrat keystone
und sahen die kleidung die sie am
samstag zur arbeit getragen hatte
ein kleid mit kraut
keine anzeichen von einem kampf in der
bonau
keine einbruchspuren
sich keine entführung oder ähnliches
abgespielt zu haben
als uns der fall gemeldet wurde sind
einige unserer ermittler zu kellys man's
shop gefahren um personen zu befragen
cables fall war sehr ungewöhnlich eine
frau wie sie mit einem festen job und
familie verschwindet nicht einfach
[Musik]
an der nächsten ecke
viele wohlhabende einflussreiche leute
haben dort eingekauft
sie kannten die inhaber gut und auch die
verkäufer
hier haben die ermittler angesetzt als
carrie grobe vermisst gemeldet wurde sie
haben die verkäufer befragt noch die
ermittler kannten das personal da sie
selbst die eingekauft haben
die mitarbeiter hatten einen engen
zusammenhang sie kannten einander privat
deshalb liefen die interviews recht
reibungslos ab sie konnten unsere fragen
zur kertész tagesablauf beantworten weil
sie kaffee gut kann zumindest dachten
sie das
sie hat seit über zehn jahren dort
gearbeitet wie die meisten verkäufer
viele kunden wurden mit ihrem namen
begrüßt wenn sie das geschäft betraten
[Musik]
dem die angestellten von kelis mails
shop waren wie eine familie
sie haben seit jahren dort gearbeitet
jeder kannte den anderen und seine
familie sie waren eng befreundet
unter den befragten war auch charles
marc er arbeitete in der schuhabteilung
er war am samstag nach ladenschluss mit
cathy zum auto gegangen sie hat darüber
gesprochen was sie am restlichen
wochenende vor hatten und über käppis
kurzurlaub von dem sie gerade
zurückgekommen war
[Musik]
er hat ihr einen schönen abend gewünscht
und jeder ging seiner wege
[Musik]
die befragung hat keine wichtigen
hinweise hervorgebracht die auf eine
spur gedeutet hätten
wir fragten ihre kollegen ob die
probleme in ihrer beziehung oder mit
einer anderen person hatte
niemand konnte uns einen tipp geben
keiner ihrer kollegen hatte eine ahnung
was passiert sein könnte
sie war einfach verschwunden
die 62 jährige campbell hatte sich kurz
nach 17 uhr von ihrem kollegen
verabschiedet und wurde danach nicht
mehr gesehen
natürlich haben wir immer wieder
vermisstenfälle wie jede stadt
aber wenn eine 62-jährige frau
verschwindet die in vollem besitz ihrer
geistigen kräfte ist dann wird das
verdächtig
wir vermuteten dass sie entweder bald
wieder auftauchen würde oder dass sie
mit ihrem auto verunglückt waren nicht
nach hilfe rufen konnte
vielleicht war sie auch spontan
weggefahren aber dann hätte sie ihre
familie bescheid gesagt
als nächstes suchen die ermittler käppis
lebenspartner auf fahrer
in jedem vermisstenfall werden zuerst
die personen befragt wie dem oder der
vermissten am nächsten stehen und der
partner ist immer der erste
hauptverdächtiger
deshalb mussten wir umgehen mit
versprechen
fred carroll erlaubte uns seine wohnung
zu durchsuchen die nur zehn autominuten
von der hauptwache entfernt lag
während die beamten seine wohnung
durchsuchen wird er zur befragung aufs
revier gebracht
[Musik]
fred carroll war rentner er war etwa
mitte 70
die beiden waren seit einigen jahren
zusammen
ergab sich ein wenig reserviert weil wir
ihm die umstände bereitet hatten für
unsere ermittlungen zu uns zu kommen
er sagte dass er kaffee wochen vor dem
kurzurlaub mit ihren freundinnen zuletzt
gesehen hatte
als er am sonntag vom angeln kam brannte
in seiner wohnung das licht
er fand den ersatzschlüssel von katys
auto in seinem wohnzimmer und ihre
blutdruckmedikamente auf dem nachttisch
das appartement wurde penibel sauber
gemacht mehr als man beim wöchentlichen
putzen erwarten würde
es roch nach chemischen
reinigungsmitteln
da drängte sich sofort der verdacht auf
dass er etwas vertuschen wollte
vielleicht hat er versucht spuren einer
straftat zu beseitigen
[Musik]
erkennst du
androsch
als ermittler achtet man darauf wie der
befragte seine sätze formuliert preetz
sprach in der vergangenheitsform über
kette und er wirkt er keineswegs so
besorgt wie jason
er wirkte eher genervt weil er zu uns
kommen und unsere fragen beantworten
musste
red sagt er dass er erst am sonntag vom
fischen zurückgekommen seien
diese tatsache hätte ihn vom verdacht
ausgeschlossen allerdings erzählte er
dass er alleine angel war es gab also
keinen zeugen für sein alibi
fred carroll blieb einer der
hauptverdächtigen in unserer ermittler
mcafee wurde gesehen wie sie am frühen
samstagabend in ihren wagen stieg nun
war es montag und seitdem hatte sie
niemand mehr gesehen
unseren ersten durchbruch hatten wir am
montagabend
die managerin des herrn
bekleidungsgeschäfts hieß christi
waldeck sie besuchte einen kurs an der
marshall university etwa 80 kilometer
von charleston entfernt
als sie auf der interstate six die
vorrichtung westen fuhr sah sie käppis
auto am straßenrand stehen
sie rief sofort einen unserer ermittler
an
wir fuhren umgehend zu ihrem wagen auf
dem weg dachte ich vielleicht hat eine
freundin cathy abgeholt und sie weiß gar
nicht dass sie als vermisst gemeldet
wurde
cafés auto stand etwa hier als die
ermittler ankamen sahen sie ein weißes
handtuch oder etwas ähnliches aus dem
fenster hängen für gewöhnlich ist das
ein zeichen dass der fahrer lieben
geblieben ist und hilfe holen wollte um
den wagen wieder zum laufen zu bringen
es signalisiert bitte nicht abschnitten
wir hatten die hoffnung dass cathy in
der nähe war oder von jemandem abgeholt
wurde so etwas lässt einen immer hoffen
wir hatten die ersatzschlüssel aus fred
carrolls wohnung so konnten wir uns
zugang zu dem wagen verschaffen
ursprünglich dachten wir sie wäre liegen
geblieben dass der wagen zur werkstatt
müsste oder keinen sprit mehr hatte
aber wir konnten ihn problemlos starten
er lief einwandfrei
da sie nicht liegen geblieben war und
der wagen neben einem dicht bewachsenen
gebiet stand ließen wir spürhunde kommen
wie man sehen kann gibt es hier viele
dornenbusch
dieser waldrand ist ziemlich zugewuchert
es wäre schwierig einen pfad zu folgen
wenn es überhaupt einen gibt wenn jemand
da hinein gegangen wäre hätte man
zerbrochene ersteren niedergetrampelt
das glas gesehen vor allem wenn man
kaffee hineingezerrt hätte oder sie ins
dickicht geflüchtet wäre es gab
keinerlei anzeichen dafür auch die
lichteren stellen ließen nicht vermuten
dass dort jemand vor kurzem mit den wald
gegangen ist
wir haben das gebiet mehrere stunden
lang abgesucht und konnten keinerlei
hinweise auf kaffee oder eine andere
person finden
eine theorie war dass sie entführt wurde
oder dass sie mit jemandem mit fuhr um
hilfe zu holen
anschließend haben wir ihren wagen für
die spurensicherung zum hauptquartier
gebracht
wir suchten nach fingerabdrücke
dna-spuren fasern waffen und blut
in dem wagen lag eine quittung von
walmart
vom samstag den 24 april
mit dieser quittung hatten wir eine neue
spur wir mussten zu dem mord fahren und
herausfinden wer dort eingekauft hatte
war es kaffee oder eine andere person
war sie in begleitung dort
wir haben die videos der
überwachungskameras beschlagnahmt
das waren mehrere stunden material die
wir von ermittlern sichten ließen
[Musik]
das ist der
mcafee war auf mehreren kameras zu sehen
wie sie dinge angeschaut und eingepackt
hat sie hat ganz normal eingekauft
[Musik]
man sieht niemanden der sie zu verfolgen
scheint
wir hofften dass uns die aufnahmen einen
hinweis geben würden wer zum zeitpunkt
ihres verschwindens beyrer
ein ganz normaler samstag abend da fährt
ein streifenwagen auf den waldparkplatz
alles völlig unauffällig
sie ist ganz normal im ort herum
geschlendert und hat eingekauft es
schien ihr niemand im geschäft
nachzustellen und er ist keiner gefolgt
hat sie wegfuhren
die videoaufnahmen zeigten keinerlei
auffälligkeiten niemand folgte ihr sie
wirkte auch nicht beunruhigt
das lieferte keine neuen hinweise
[Musik]
wir wussten dass sie danach zu treffen
einige dinge die sie eingekauft hatte
waren in seiner wohnung zb kaufte sie
ein abdruck gestell für geschirr stand
auf der quittung man sah es auf dem
video und es befand sich in seiner
wohnung
die überwachungsvideos von walmart
liefern keine heiße spur dann erhalten
sie neue informationen die ihren
hauptverdächtigen entlasten
wir konnten uns die mobilfunkdaten von
fred carrolls handy beschaffen und
feststellen wann er wo gewesen ist
sie bestätigten dass er in dem genannten
gebiet angeln war und dass er am sonntag
nach charleston zurück gefahren ist
aufgrund dessen konnten wir fred carroll
vom verdacht ausschließen
eine theorie die wir diskutierten war
okay vielleicht ihr leben in charleston
hinter sich lassen wollte
so etwas kommt immer wieder vor sei es
aus finanziellen persönlichen oder auch
gesundheitlichen gründen aber
ich kannte sie
hatte ein so enges verhältnis zu ihren
söhnen
diese theorie kam für mich nicht in
frage
es gab zahlreiche gerüchte was mit cathy
passiert sein könnte dass sie mit
jemandem durchgebrannt sein oder von
einem fremden mitgenommen und entführt
wurde
wir sind jeder spur nachgegangen aber
alle führt ins leere
bis freitag wurde habe ich mir richtig
sorgen gemacht
hier schien wirklich etwas zugestoßen zu
sein
dann erhielten wir katys
einzelverbindungsnachweis sie hatte am
samstagabend zwei anrufe erhalten
an dem abend als sie verschwand
die auflistung zeigte dass sie mit ihrem
ex mann david mccarthy und mit einer
freundin engländers gesprochen hatte
mccartney wurde auf der hauptwache
befragt wie sich herausstellte war
kaffee an dem besagten samstagabend bei
ihm gewesen
[Musik]
cathy es zu seinem haus gefahren um ein
paar mahlzeiten und seine medizin für
ihn vorzubereiten
er hatte einen schlaganfall erlitten
seitdem kümmerte sie sich um ihn
[Musik]
die beiden hatten ein herzliches
verhältnis zu dem was david recht
gebrechlich wir konnten ihn also vom
verdacht ausschließen
[Musik]
das zweite telefonat führte sie mit
ihrer freundin engländers
wir sprachen mit engländers sie
bestätigte dass sie an dem abend mit
kaffee telefoniert hatte
für head kommt morgen zurück wir sehen
gerade erst angekommen kann ich dich
später zurückruft
nein
bevor sie auf legte sagte cathy wir
fahren gleich zu fretz wohnung
nach diesem hinweis stellte sich die
frage wer mit cathy zur fratze partner
und gefahren war
das war ein kleiner durchbruch
offensichtlich war jemand bei ihr
gewesen nun mussten wir herausfinden um
wen es sich handelte
doch trotz aller anstrengungen können
die ermittler nicht herausfinden wer
kaffee zu fred ference wohnung begleitet
hat so wird die einzige heiße spur die
die polizei hat mit der zeit kalt
es gab zahlreiche theorien und gerüchte
manche vermuteten dass sie irgendwo ein
neues leben beginnen wollte
andere mutmaßen dass ihr übel
mitgespielt wurde man fragt sich immer
was das schlimmste szenario wäre
hofft aber auf das beste
[Musik]
es waren bereits mehrere wochen
verstrichen
alle spuren hatten ins leere geführt
wir bekamen keine hinweise mehr von der
bevölkerung wir saßen in einer sackgasse
als leitender ermittler war ich in einer
schwierigen situation
ich wollte diesen fall lösen noch dazu
konnte ich diese familie
es ist
ich stand unter druck permanent unter
druck
es war frustrierend für mich
und jeden anderen unsere ermittler
wir hatten das gefühl kontinuierlich
gegen eine wand zu laufen
keine fährte führte irgendwohin das war
für alle frustrierend
wir sind noch einmal zu kärlich swans
shop gefahren um katies kollegen zu
befragen
wir hatten erfahren dass sie an dem
besagten samstag
mit einem freund zu mittag gegessen
hatte
es handelte sich um einen arzt aus der
gegend den sie in dem geschäft kennen
gelernt hatte
sie hätten sich im laufe der zeit
angefreundet
wir haben den arzt zur befragung aufs
revier bringen lassen
[Musik]
der arzt erzählte uns dass kaffee und er
eine affäre
und dass sie in der woche vor cafés
verschwinden in kalifornien gewesen
waren
sie hat ihren freunden und ihrer familie
erzählt dass sie mit freundinnen
weggefahren war tatsächlich war es ein
romantischer kurzurlaub
[Musik]
als wir von ihrer affäre erfuhren
horchten wir auf das weckte unseren
verdacht
jetzt hatten wir eine neue spur was war
hier passiert
der arzt erzählte uns dass er am abend
ihres verschwindens zu hause bei seiner
frau war wir haben diskret nachgeforscht
und
konnten sein alibi bestätigen
die spur war erledigt wieder sackgasse
[Musik]
freunde und seine familie haben sucht
plakate und flyer verteilt ein
schulfreund von uns erstellte eine
website die über den fall informierte
und um hinweise
basis verschwinden schürte ängste
die leute wollten antworten partie war
sehr beliebt
es war deprimierend den leuten zu sagen
dass wir keine weiteren hinweise hatten
mittlerweile hat kathi goebels familie
ihre eigene theorie zu ihrem
verschwinden
jason hat einige jahre lang in myrtle
beach als privatdetektiv gearbeitet
er hatte seiner mutter viel darüber
erzählt wie menschen abtauchen
man besorgt sich ein zweites handy unter
einem anderen namen und so weiter
erklärt
wie man woanders ein neues leben
beginnen könnte
anklam zum ball
und er war überzeugt dass sie genau das
getan hatte
wir hatten alle möglichkeiten
ausgeschöpft und erhielten keine
hinweise mehr das nagt an einem wir
konnten nicht herausfinden was mit café
global passiert war oder wo sie sich
befanden
und da war jason die an dass seine
mutter suchte
aber die monate vergingen und wir
erhielten keine neuen informationen
ich habe mich so manches mal gefragt ob
wir diesen fall noch lösen würden
man fragt sich immer wieder was hätten
wir anders machen können welcher spur
hätten wir weiter nachgehen sollen
es beschäftigte mich dass wir ihr auto
hatten und ihr offensichtlich etwas
zugestoßen war er aber nicht
herausfinden konnten ob der täter ihr
nahe stand oder ob es ein fremder aus
der gegend war in der ihr wagen entdeckt
wurde
ich fühlte eine doppelte last auf meinen
schultern
zum einen hatte ich den beruflichen
ehrgeiz dieses verbrechen aufzuklären
zum anderen kannte ich diese dame seit
meiner kindheit
ich kannte ihre kinder und wollte ihnen
antworten liefern
[Musik]
in den zwei jahren nach käppis
verschwinden wurde jedes jahr eine
mahnwache mit kerzen für sie abgehalten
vor kelly smith shop
es fiel mir jedes mal schwer den leuten
sagen zu müssen dass wir keine weiteren
anhaltspunkte hatten
ich wollte nicht mit diesem ungelösten
fall aus dem dienst scheiden
[Musik]
wir hatten gerade
plötzlich kam der sheriff eingerannt er
holte mich und einen anderen ermittler
und sagte wir hatten soeben einen notruf
der anrufer hatte im garten seines
vaters gearbeitet
ihm war zuvor eine senke aufgefallen
aber sein vater hat ihn zurück gepfiffen
und gesagt
darum brauchst du dich nicht zu kümmern
an dem tag des anrufs
wollte er die stelle dann doch
ausbessern er dachte dass ich dort
wasser angesammelt hätte
[Musik]
also begann er die erde weg zu räumen
und stieß dabei auf knochen
als er weiter group stieß er auf noch
mehr knochen scheinbar waren das
menschliche überreste
er schaufelte weiter und fand eine
plastiktüte
darin sah er menschliche haare
hat er die polizei gerufen
[Musik]
anfangs war unsere informationslage
dürftig aber ich dachte sofort ob das
wohl carey ist
[Musik]
als wir ankamen standen etliche autos am
straßenrand
es war schwer zu dem von dort zu
gelangen weil viele menschen hier waren
und die zufahrt eng ist sie hatten
bereits mit der ausgrabung begonnen
an der fundstelle wurde ein zelt
aufgestellt um sie vor dem regen zu
schützen
überall war absperrband das waren
zahlreiche ermittler und
kriminaltechniker vor ort
wir kamen an und gingen zu der von
stellen
als ich die überreste sah war mir sofort
klar dass sie von einem menschen stammt
und dass es sich wahrscheinlich um cathy
kobel handelte
[Musik]
der mann der den notruf abgesetzt hat
sie es mit nachnamen markt
wie sich herausstellte war sein vater
charles
maffays langjähriger kollege
er wurde an dem tag ihre
vermisstenmeldung befragt
damals gab es keine stichhaltigen
indizien um ihn als verdächtigen
anzusehen aber tatsächlich war er genau
das
wir hatten einen plan wir wussten dass
charles marge bei der arbeit kein handy
bei sich trug und wie es aussah hatte
keiner der anwesenden gewarnt dass sie
in seinem haus war
also sind die taktischen afa und ich zu
dem geschäft gefahren
ich war aufgeregt und nervös ich wollte
dort sein bevor sich die nachricht
verbreitete dass wir eine leiche in
seinem garten gefunden hatten
[Musik]
natürlich wird man schneller man spürt
das adrenalin
[Musik]
ich habe mich die ganze fahrt über
gefragt wie ich das gespräch beginnen
sollte
wie sollte ich ihm eröffnen dass wir
eine leiche in seinem garten gefunden
hatten und ihn dazu kriegen wir die
wahrheit zu erzählen
[Musik]
wir betraten das geschäft und gingen auf
charles marge
wir fragten sind sie teils marge er
antwortete der bin ich ich stellte mich
und direktes nah vor
dann sagte ich wie sie wissen ist katie
vor fast genau zwei jahren verschwunden
wir möchten einigen dingen noch einmal
nachgehen dürften wir sie dazu befragen
er war sehr sympathisch und höflich wir
erklärten ihm dass wir ihm ein paar
fragen stellen wollten um mehr
informationen zu sammeln
er sagte ja klar ich fragte ihn ob er
mit uns aufs revier kommen würde er
meinte ja kein problem
wir boten ihm an ihn mitzunehmen
er könne aber auch mit seinem auto
fahren er meinte er hätte kein auto und
fragte ob wir mitnehmen können
wir gingen raus zum wagen charles nahm
auf dem beifahrersitz platz
er wirkte etwas nervös man merkte dass
er wissen wollte was wir ihn fragen
würden
ich führte ihn nach oben in eines
unserer verhörzimmer ich bat ihn sich zu
setzen und sagte dass ich gleich zurück
sein würde dann ließ ich ihn allein
[Musik]
ich habe mit freundlichem smalltalk
begonnen
ich wollte einen eindruck bekommen wie
er reagiert deshalb habe ich erst mal
ganz normal mit ihm geredet
im raum den hals
ich merkte wie sich sein verhalten
änderte die schlagader an seinem hals
begann zu pulsieren
er wurde nervös
dann eröffnete ich ihm dass wir auf
seinem grundstück waren eine
durchsuchung durchführten und in seinem
garten eine leiche aus gruben
damit hatten wir unsere karten
aufgedeckt
erst auf dem stuhl zusammen gesagt seine
stimme wurde leiser
[Applaus]
ich wäre einfach falsch
er erklärte mir dass cathy sterben
wollte cathy sei auf ihn zugekommen
sie habe probleme mit einem ihrer söhne
gehabt und charles bezahlt damit er sie
tötet
bei mir läuteten die alarmglocken als er
mir das erzählte ich wusste wie nahe sie
ihren söhnen stand und dass sie keine
probleme hatten charles erzählte mir
nicht die wahrheit
als er schilderte wie er den hals
zugedrückt hat und sie gesagt habe tue
es tue es wusste ich dass er
wenn man jemanden erwirkt und ihm die
kehle zugedrückt hat derjenige nicht
genug luft in der lunge um einen
anzuspornen charles erzählt nicht die
wahrheit
[Musik]
sie fanden sechs einzelne körperteile er
hatte ihre leiche zerstückelt
bei der ausgrabung fanden sie dinge die
karte gehörten an einer anderen adresse
fanden sie weitere
[Musik]
es war aufschlussreich wie er cathy und
die tat geschrieben hat
ein café zu einem objekt gemacht haben
wir alle arten an dem tag sehr gemischte
gefühle
es war eine traurige situation für jeden
swatch hat über 30 jahre in kellys
mensch abgearbeitet er hat täglich mit
cathy und ihren kollegen gesprochen
er vermittelte den anschein ein netter
kerl zu sein wir haben eine seiner
ehemaligen partnerinnen ausfindig
gemacht die ihn anders beschrieb sie
sagte dass er einen starken sextrieb
hatte er habe permanent sex gewollt und
sei etwas pervers gewesen er verlangte
jedes mal danach wenn sie sich sahen
angesichts des telefonats dass cathy mit
ihrer freundin entführte vermuten wir
dass charles mit ihren fritz wohnung war
vermutlich hat sie danach zu sich
gelockt
[Musik]
dort hat er sie wahrscheinlich
überwältigt und getötet
[Applaus]
als charles marge in untersuchungshaft
saß versuchte er selbstmord zu begehen
er sprang aus dem fenster verletzte sich
und wurde auf der krankenbahre in den
gerichtssaal gerollt
am ende hat er sich des vorsätzlichen
mordes für schuldig bekannt
[Musik]
selbst nach all den jahren bei der
polizei
kann ich noch immer nicht fassen
wie jemand einem anderen menschen etwas
derart barbarisches antun kann
ich vermute dass charles eine beziehung
mit cathy wollte catherine abwies und er
sich nahm was er nicht kriegen konnte
[Musik]